nach langer zwangspause legt heute zum
ersten mal wieder ein großes
kreuzfahrtschiff von einem deutschen
hafen ab vom hamburger hafen und zwar um
21.30 dass mein schiff 2
doch natürlich wird das keine normale
kreuzfahrt werden unter welchen
bedingungen die kreuzfahrt jetzt
stattfindet das weiß unsere bild
reporterin franziska ringleben denn sie
durfte sich schon einmal umschauen
wir befinden uns jetzt hier im hamburger
hafen am terminal steinwerder hier fährt
nachher die mein schiff 2 von tui
cruises los richtung norwegen und hier
hat sich auch alles geändert durch
bewohner beim check-in alles ist
kontaktlos man muss forschen online
alles einfüllen man muss ein gesundheits
bogen ausfüllen und mitbringen und bevor
man überhaupt an bord darf normativer
gemessen
ich habe eine sehr beliebte frage wer
ist der beste kapitän und die antwort
ist immer der der die beste besatzung
mannschaft hat unsere mannschaft hat
jetzt einen monat lang trainiert die
haben nichts anderes gemacht als
abstände benehmen regeln der hygiene
gesundheit die besatzung ist
hervorragend trainiert und geschult also
ich lehne mich ganz beruhigt zurück und
ich ermögliche einfach nur meinem team
dass es wirklich das schiff sauber und
sicher hält und gesund also ich bin da
ganz entspannt zur zeit und jetzt
befinden wir uns ja auf dem grössten pc
restaurant an bord und hier ist ganz
wichtig man muss sich erstmal hier an
das system hier eingang und ausgang
halten
man muss sich vor die hände gewaschen
haben und dann hier auch noch frisch die
hände desinfizieren
dann heißt es auch nicht auf die plätze
fertig los nein man muss warten bis man
an seinen tisch gebracht wird und dann
geht man sich seinen speisen aus und
bekommt sie dann auch sony hand gedrückt
und darf nicht selbst messer und gabel
anfassen und wichtig an bord ist sie
wirklich immer den sicherheitsabstand
einzuhalten deswegen liegen überall
solche zettel auf jedem zweiten tisch
dass dieser tisch abgesagt ist dass
dieser frei bleiben muss und am tisch
muss man keinen mundschutz tragen
deswegen darf ich jetzt hier auch so
sitzen aber das personal ist ganze zeit
mit zu einem plexiglas mit dem classic
schutz vor den augen abgesichert dass
sowohl wir als erste als auch sie als
mitarbeiter und um geschützt wird
wir befinden uns jetzt hier im board
hospital das jetzt vor dieser ersten
reise
stark aufgestockt wurde das heißt es
gibt noch mehr deutsche
krankenschwestern und noch mehr ärzte an
bord
es gibt ein größeres größere
möglichkeiten schnell test durchzuführen
und es wird täglich bei den passagieren
die gesundheit abgefragt und fieber
gemessen
denn jetzt ist alles anders wenn man es
sich nicht so gut fühlt dann kommt man
nicht direkt hier hin sondern ruft an
und dann kommt der arzt direkt auf die
kabine denn falls es dann doch symptome
seien sollten die auf coop 19 sprechen
möchte man da die höchste sicherheit
auch damit gewährleisten können und für
die passagiere die sie hinter mir sehen
geht es heute abend schon auf reise für
bild und die 30 glücklichen krone helden
gewinner geht es montag hervor sehen